Somehow these
elephants are eking out
a living in a landscape
that anyone else would think is lifeless.
Conservationist Dr.
Paula Kahumbu has spent her career
studying the elephants of Africa's lush
savanna grasslands.
But she's never laid
eyes on a desert elephant.
She wants to find out
how these remarkable animals
managed to survive
in this unforgiving place.
African savanna elephants and desert
elephants are the same species.
But if you took a savanna elephant
and brought it here, it wouldn't survive.
I want to know how these desert elephants
managed to live here.
To find one of the constantly roaming
elephant herds,
Paula has turned to tracker
Hendrik Moon in Bomi
and his 25 years of studying
the Desert Elephant.
I think some walk through a soft
so it's possible
we’ll find them today.
Oh, this amazing
there’s two here.
Oh, you mean theres a big family here.
Yeah.
These are the desert elephants
we've been looking for.
This family.
I've been watching elephants
my whole life,
and I've never seen elephants like these.
They may be the same species
as savanna elephants,
but you can immediately
see the differences.
The legs have less fat in them,
so they look taller
and their skin is looser.
It's incredibly tough for an elephant
here.
Food and water are both scarce
and it's only getting worse
in the Namib desert.
Climate change has brought with it
a five year drought.
Everything depends on their ability
to get from one waterhole to the next.
There's no time to stop,
to investigate, to explore how to play.
It's just survive.
Survive means keep going.
Keep going.